[Musique]
charlot 8 né le 30 juin 14 270 au
château d'amboise
il le seul fils du roi louis ix 11 et de
la reine charlotte de savoie
il a cependant deux soeurs plus âgés
jeanne de france et anne de france qui
vont chacune jouer un rôle très
particulier
selon la seule volonté du roi des sons
plus bas âge de dauphin louis oms va
utiliser ce fils à des fins politiques
au gré des promesses de mariage qui
n'aboutissent pas c'est d'abord pendant
longtemps un roi sous tutelle trop jeune
pour régner à la mort de son père
ce dernier va imposer la soeur du
dauphin anne de france plus connu sous
le nom d'anne de beaujeu la fille en
laquelle louis 11 à une parfaite
confiance et pour laquelle il voue une
admiration sans borne va donc assurer
une régence plutôt brillante de 14 183 à
14 100 91
bien entendu la haute noblesse souvent
malmené par louis 11 conteste la
légitimité de cette gouvernance la loi
salique n'est pas une oie
particulièrement féministe d'où des
intrigues et complots fomentés par les
grands noms du royaume que la régente va
régler avec force intelligence et
fermeté à la manière de son père qui dit
d'elle en tout lieu c'est la femme la
moins folle de france car pour sage je
n'en connais point la vie est donc le
court règne de charles ix 8 vont être
rythmée par des personnages des périodes
et des événements qui échappent souvent
à la volonté même du souverain une
enfance à amboise peu studieuse et
surprotégé la région de sa soeur anne où
le problème breton où la guerre folle la
première guerre d'italie les prémices de
la renaissance artistique et
architecturale en france retour d'italie
anne de bretagne une première fois à
rennes la mort précoce en conclusion il
faut ici rappeler que la renaissance
politique initiée par lyon et qui
affirme la puissance et l'unité du
royaume autour du roi de france va se
poursuivre charlot 8 sur les conseils
avisés de son père qui se préoccupe
enfin de son fils au terme de sa vie va
garder l'administration de ce dernier sa
méthode de gouvernance qui privilégie
les compétences au détriment des droits
de sang revendiquée par la haute
noblesse
malheureusement charles 8 ne peut
achever son oeuvre royal il meurt
bêtement en heurtant alain taux de
portes au château d'amboise en se
rendant au jeu de paume le 7 avril 14
198 un règne effectif de 7 ans de 14 à
191 à 14 198 ne permet pas à l'histoire
de statuer pleinement sur l'oeuvre
politique du personnage c'est en quelque
sorte une symphonie inachevée
d'autant plus que le souverain et sa
femme anne de bretagne ne peuvent donner
à la france un héritier mâle de dauphin
charles orlan et charles meurt en bas
âge
la branche direct des valois c'est un
dock elle sera remplacée par la branche
cadette des valois orléans que louis
d'orléans futur louis xii va incarner de
nos jours charles wuyts souverain
méconnu et éphémères laissent quand même
de son passage à la tête du royaume
l'image d'un homme d'une grande bonté de
coeur d'une amabilité naturel d'où ce
surnom passé à la postérité
charles la fable cela vient sans nul
doute du plus profond de son enfance au
château d'amboise auprès de sa mère
charlotte de savoie est loin d'un père
louis 11 exclusivement préoccupés par la
politique de reconquête et d'unité du
royaume de france
il ne faut pas oublier non plus et ce
n'est pas négligeable qu'il est le
premier souverain a importé d'italie la
renaissance en france
[Musique]
charles le dauphin de viennois titre
obligé de l'héritier du trône de france
pas ses premières années de vie au
château d'amboise édifice puissamment
fortifiée dominant la loire il est tenu
à l'écart de la cour mais n'est pas
isolé pour autant sa mère la reine
charlotte de savoie est souvent auprès
de lui là aussi des compagnons de jeu de
son âge 500 personnes au moins sont
chargés nuitées jour de veiller sur ce
petit personnage malingre pourtant si
important pour la continuité de la
dynastie des valois le dauphin est par
ailleurs d'une santé très fragile et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le roi
surveille de très près ce qui se passe à
angoisses et envoie d'incessantes
instruction qui ont vu quelque peu
étouffé les serviteurs qu'ils avaient
placées autour du dauphin hyper
protection rapprochée soins médicaux
attentif et distraction voilà le résumé
du quotidien de charles jusqu'à l'âge de
12 entre le roi lion se confie le destin
du dauphin à son homme de confiance et
amis gens bourrés seigneur du plessis
indiquant à ce dernier de privilégier
l'éducation physique jugée plus propice
au développement difficile du corps de
l'enfant au détriment du latin
heureusement le précepteur humaniste
guillaume tardif lui inculque une
formation morale et intellectuelle qu'il
sera pas étrangère à la légendaire
amabilités la courtoisie et la grande
bonté de charles 8
l'éducation physique au grand air ça
vernet au moins payant au niveau de la
santé et charles devient rapidement un
excellent cavalier passionné également
par la fauconnerie et le jeu de paume
louis 11 ne se préoccupe pas ou peu de
son à l'héritier jusqu'à l'âge de 12 ans
sentant le déclin de sa santé il va à
partir de 14 à 181 penser à une possible
passation de pouvoir il tient à initier
lui même le dauphin à la chose politique
autour de 4 grands concepts prudence
tempérance force et justice quant à sa
formation intellectuelle
elle semble avoir été assez peu poussé
du moins est il en mesure après une
instruction élémentaire de base de lire
peu avant la mort de son père des
ouvrages que celui ci lui fait envoyer
comme les grandes chronique de france
l'histoire officielle du royaume ou
encore le rosier des guerres qui est un
traité politique d'éducation du prince
que l'on a fait spécialement composée à
son intention une recontre cela n'est là
lieu entre le père et le fils en
septembre 14 280 2 à amboise comme vrai
père est tenu et doit instruire et
enseigné son fils
suite à cette rencontre une ordonnance
est édité deux mois plus tard
clairement le roi conseils à son fils de
gouverner comme lui sans rien changer à
cette administration efficace et fidèle
dans l'intérêt premier d'un état
puissant fédérer autour du pouvoir royal
les conseils des grands du royaume
peuvent être écoutées à condition qu'il
soit issu de la propre ligne et est du
propre sang du dauphin cela laisse
deviner le dessin de louis 11 te confier
le gouvernement de la france à quelqu'un
de très proche en l'occurrence sa fille
anne lyon se fait approuvé publiquement
devant les grands du royaume
cette fameuse ordonnance intronisant le
dauphin et que celui ci va décliner
oralement au château d'amboise monsieur
à l'aide de dieu et quand son bon
plaisir sera que les choses adviennent
jeu obéirait à vos commandement et
plaisir et ferez en tiendrez et
accomplir est ce que vous avez en juin
commandez et en charge et mais ce que
louis 11 et sa fille sans nul doute
omettre de révéler aux dauphins et qu'on
ne peut passer sous silence c'est le
rôle politique que le père a fait jouer
à son fils durant son enfance
en 14 275 le traité de picquigny qui met
officiellement fin la guerre de cent ans
s'accompagne d'une promesse de mariage
entre le dauphin charles et elisabeth
d'york fille du roi henri iv
d'angleterre mais en 14 277 à la mort de
charles le téméraire sous prétexte
d'unifier les états de bourgogne louis
11 promet son fils à marie de bourgogne
qui malheureusement meurt
accidentellement
qu'à cela ne tienne le roi de france
décide alors de fiancé charles à
marguerite de bourgogne fille de la
défunte et qui est âgé de seulement
trois ans alors la décision du mariage
entre le dauphin charles et marguerite
de bourgogne va provoquer la colère du
roi d'angleterre edouard iv
d'abord parce qu'il a été joué les
accords de pikine hills et ans plus tôt
avait prévu de marielle dauphin à sa
propre fille aînée elizabeth d'york et
louis 11 avait toujours tirer prétexte
de leur jeune âge à l'un et à l'autre
pour différer cette union ensuite le
mariage du dauphin et de marguerite de
bourgogne brise l'alliance tournée
contre la france qui unissait edouard iv
au père de marguerite maximilien
d'autriche marguerite de bourgogne vite
à la cour d'amboise avec son dauphin de
fiancé mais l'intérêt supérieur de
l'état a réservé une autre épouse achard
le 8 grâce sans doute au talent
visionnaire et au pragmatisme dan de
france
la régente
au lendemain de la mort de son père anne
va devoir cependant faire face à la
grogne de certains grands du royaume
néanmoins le 30 mai 484 charles 8 est
armé chevalier est couronné roi de
france en la cathédrale de reims avec
tous les honneurs et apparat qui
conviennent à un grand personnage
d'europe
mais charles est trop jeune pour
gouverner tout seul
[Musique]
[Rires]
lady de majorité de 13 174 autorise le
jeune roi charles ii 8 a régné à
condition qu'il soit assisté d'un
conseil il deviendra très jeune à
présent et il est complètement sous
tutelle de la régente désigné par louis
11 avalisé par les états généraux qui
est anne de beaujeu lyon avant sa mort a
clairement désigné sa fille anne pour
veiller sur le jeune roi et conduire
avec lui le gouvernement du royaume mais
à sa mort son cousin le duc louis
d'orléans revendique par le sang la
tutelle de charles c'est la régente du
royaume
elle a tous les pouvoirs elle s'arrange
pour écarter son beau frère louis
d'orléans le futur louis xii et
vos frères et cousins aussi parce que ce
sont des aussi les orléans sont des
descendants des capétiens louis
d'orléans et le successeur naturel de
charles si celui ci décède ou s'il n'a
pas d'enfant mâle de surcroît louis est
marié à jeanne de france fille aînée de
louis 11 jeanne malgré sa grande bonté
et l'aide est fort mal constituée elle
est totalement ignorée de son mari
c'est un mariage initiée par le rusé roi
défunt pour intégrer le duché d'orléans
au royaume de france
mais louis d'orléans à d'autres
soumissions le parti aristocratique
redresse aussitôt la tête et s'unit au
tour du jeune duc d'orléans louis
d'orléans qui va revendiquer pour
lui-même la tutelle du roi et le
gouvernement du royaume comme ils
n'arrivent pas à l'obtenir il va leur
réclamer la convocation des états
généraux pour trancher cette question
politique de première importance
et comme nous sommes à ce moment dans un
contexte de réaction inévitable après
l'autoritarisme du règne précédent
les beaux jeux sont obligés d'accepter
mais ils vont prendre un certain nombre
de précautions et en particulier pour la
première fois on va organiser de
véritables élections pour envoyer des
députés et les beaux jeux vont
s'arranger pour un bon nombre de ses
députés soient des officiers royaux
attachés à l'état royal à l'oeuvre du
défunt roi est à leur service
manoeuvrant habilement et rappelant
l'ordonance d'amboise à n'enlève
l'adhésion des représentants des trois
états noblesse clergé et tiers état
usant de compromis elle confie la
présidence du conseil du roi à louis
d'orléans en imposant une présence
constante d'elle et de son mari pierre
de beaujeu ducs de bourbons auprès de
charles 8
louis ne tarde pas à comprendre la
supercherie et entre en rébellion
entraînant avec lui quelques grands du
royaume
le duc d'alençon le prince d'orange le
compte du noah leconte d'angoulême père
de françois 1er
le duc de lorraine et le duc françois ii
de bretagne
ainsi commence la guerre folle qui va
durer de 14 985 à 14 100 88 la guerre
folle qui comprendra plusieurs épisodes
au fil des années 1480 et qui fait écho
à la guerre du bien public sous
brouillon est une tentative de
l'opposition aristocratique pour prendre
par les armes le contrôle du royaume et
de la personne royale dans ce même temps
anne de beaujeu matt énergiquement en
compagnie de son frère qui fait alors
ses premiers pas de chef de guerre
auprès du brillant maréchal de gier une
révolte des seniors du sud-ouest de la
france est pris d'une soudaine
indépendance les comtes de foix et
d'albret ce premier acte de fermeté va
asseoir définitivement l'autorité de la
régente auprès de charles ix 8 et de la
noblesse française en général un de
france
wang beau jeu puis anne de bourbon est
une femme qui hérite de la clairvoyance
de l'énergie
la russe politique la fermeté et du sens
de l'état de son père louis 11
on dit d'elle une main de fer dans des
gants de velours à de france tom de beau
jeu c'est la fille aînée survivante de
louis 11 comme lui c'est une tête
politique et elle va avec son mari
pierre de bourbon le cir de beau jeu
dont le rôle politique a été
sous-estimée par beaucoup d'historiens
prendre la tête du parti des héritiers
politiques de louis 11
elle va s'attacher à maintenir l'oeuvre
de son père ancien protégé de louis 11
leduc est un homme intègre et honnête
qui va aider sa femme avec force et
amour en prodiguant de précieux conseils
et l'oeuvre aussi avec grand talent au
rétablissement des finances à la mise au
pas des grands féodaux à
l'agrandissement du royaume à l'unité de
la france autour de l' autorité
incontestable du roi elle arrive à avoir
toute une période
d'influents ce certaine mais une
influence plutôt bénéfique si l'on
regarde le bilan des états généreux 2484
où l'on commence à avoir une vision un
peu intellectuel qui préfigure la
renaissance de ce que doit être un
royaume moderne la guerre folle va
permettre aussi à anne de parfaire
l'apprentissage politique de charles ix
8 afin de montrer la puissance du roi de
france dans l'europe entière
elle voit dans le soutien du duc
françois ii à louis d'orléans
l'occasion rêvée de réaliser une subtile
opération d'agrandissement du royaume
durant trois ans l'armée royale confiée
aux stratèges louis de la trémoille va
prendre les villes bretonnes importantes
telles dinan dole fougères saint malo
malgré une résistance souvent héroïque
d'une armée bretonne sous les ordres du
maréchal de rieux charles 8 suit de près
le déroulement des nombreuses opérations
militaires depuis le château du verger
près d'angers trêve pourparlers
infructueux reprise des hostilités
traité non respectés jeu d'alliances qui
se font et se défont morts par milliers
ainsi se déroule cette drôle de guerre
en de france inculque à son frère
l'opiniâtreté nécessaire qui doit mener
à la victoire
28 juillet 14 288 à
saint-aubin-du-cormier s'engage la
dernière bataille décisive de la guerre
folle 6000 breton et 1500 français
perdent la vie françois ii est vaincu
louis d'orléans est les grands féodaux
rebelles sont faits prisonniers
charlot 8 dit alors de cette bataille
quelle douleur pour nous qu'une telle
multitude d'hommes étaient été tués
ceci est le plus grand carnage qui soit
survenue de mémoire d'homme la paix dont
conclut le traité du verger se signent
les 19 et 20 août à sablé sur sarthe
françois 2 ducs de bretagne doit
désormais l'hommage lige au roi de
france
le duc de bretagne ne peut marier ses
filles sans le consentement du roi de
france françois 2 laisse quatre places
fortes en garantie
saint-aubin-du-cormier dinan fougères et
saint malo
si la guerre folle cesse l'épisode
breton n'en est pas pour autant terminé
louis de relais on est enfermé pour
trois ans dans la grosse tour de bourges
ses comparses bizarrement sont amnistiés
on reconnaît là le sens de la politique
d'anne de beaujeu qui permet au roi
d'avoir ainsi une mainmise plus
prégnante sur leur fief et de confirmer
son autorité mais anne de beaujeu
poursuit un but plus royal le devenir du
puissant duché de bretagne
elle veut que cessent les relations
étroites que la péninsule entretient
depuis toujours au niveau commercial et
stratégique avec l'angleterre
elle connaît parfaitement la situation
politique outre-manche et la rivalité
entre les maisons d'york et de lancastre
qui minent la politique étrangère de la
perfide albion
elle attend patiemment l'événement
propice qui ne tarde pas survenir
françois 2 ducs de bretagne meurt
accidentellement le 9 septembre 14 188
et sa fille anne devient duchesse
cette dernière sur une promesse de son
défunt père épouse par procuration le
futur empereur du saint empire romain
germanique
maximilien le 19 décembre 14 990
malheureusement pour maximilien ce
mariage est une violation du traité du
verger karan n'a pas demander le
consentement du roi de france
une nouvelle crise éclate au printemps
14 191 entre la france et la bretagne
charles ou 8 mai le siège devant rennes
où réside la duchesse la ville ce rang
anne de bretagne se retrouvent dans les
filets de la régente et de son frère
finalement la seule option vraiment
viable la plus satisfaisante pour les
intérêts du royaume de france c'est que
la duchesse anne épouse charles wuyts
lui même mais ça pose des problèmes
parce que charles wuyts ancêtre marié à
marguerite de bourgogne anne de france
la dame de beau jeu est elle-même
réticente face à cette solution parce
qu'elle est elle l avait été partisans
du mariage avec marguerite de bourgogne
mais elle finit par se plier à la raison
d'état et part déclaré elle-même que
c'est la meilleure solution pour
pacifier le royaume sur les conseils
avisés donne de beaux jeux anne de
bretagne après avoir refusé des
promesses de mariage princier en france
ce fillon son roi charles ix 8 à la
chapelle des jacobins à rennes
ce dernier peut craindre à juste titre
le légitime courroux de maximilien
d'autriche
mais l'empereur ne peut se permettre
d'intervenir militairement occupé au
nord par des flamands turbulent au sud
de l' empire par des troubles en grès
anne de beaujeu bien renseignés c'est
tout cela
un autre problème de taille subsistent
charles ou 8 est déjà fiancée sur ordre
de louis 11 à marguerite d'autriche
fille du premier lit de maximilien et
qui vit toujours à la cour de france la
petite reine est tout simplement
répudier pour raisons politiques
et c'est charles ou 8 en personne qui
lui annonce cette terrible nouvelle
on le peut mesurer la déception de
marguerite qui toute sa vie va garder
une énorme rancoeur envers la france le
malheur de l'autrichienne n'affecte
nullement anne de beaujeu qui organise
le plus rapidement possible le mariage
de son frère le 6 décembre 14 291 anne
de bretagne épouse officiellement
charlot 8 au château de langeais les
injonctions de l'autriche auprès de la
papauté restent vaines et innocent 8
valide sans rechigner en lentilles
datant l'union du roi de france et de la
duchesse de bretagne sans doute le pape
at-il besoin du roi de france et de la
puissance militaire de celui ci
c'est le jour du mariage que la finesse
politique et la vision à long terme
d'anne de beaujeu atteignent des sommets
elle fait d'ajouter au contrat de
mariage une clause d'importance capitale
en cas d'absence d'héritier mâle la
duchesse de bretagne ne pourra se
remarier qu'avec le successeur du roi de
france
[Musique]
par ce traité très dur pour la duchesse
elle doit céder à charlo 8 les droits
qu'elle tient de son père sur le duché
de bretagne elle devient reine de france
mais elle perd le titre de duchesse de
bretagne elle perd l'administration du
duché et elle doit accepter au cas où
son mari mourait le premier sans
héritier de n'épousez aucun autre que le
futur roi de france les clauses de ce
contrat de mariage sont vraiment destiné
à s'assurer que la bretagne quoi qu'il
advienne n'échappera plus à la couronne
de france et elle va d'ailleurs après
son mariage quitté la bretagne pour la
cour de france et n'y remettra plus les
pieds du vivant de son mari le royaume
de france a grandi durablement d'une
manière notoire
même si officiellement le rattachement
ne sera effectif que durant le règne de
françois 1er
avec ce mariage prend fin la fluence
d'anne de beaujeu sur le roi de france
qui se lassent de l'importance politique
de sa soeur et qui entend désormais
gouverner la france seule conformément à
la loi salique en vigueur sous la
régence officieuse des bourgs jeu le
royaume a surmonté les guerres civiles
et échapper à la ruine de l'oeuvre
politique de louis 11 l'autorité royale
a réussi à se maintenir
anne de beaujeu à la mort de son mari
pierre de beau jeu va gouverner le duché
de bourbon et faire montre dans celui-ci
de toute l'étendue de sa maîtrise et de
son expérience en matière d'organisation
politique elle a pris une part active à
la construction patients de la puissance
du royaume prince amadouer paix aux
frontières finances rétablies
fonctionnement administratif de l'état
assuré superficie de la france de quatre
cent cinquante mille kilomètres carrés
15 millions d'habitants
mais charles wuyts aimons sip et son
premier acte notoire de souverain tout
puissant sans prendre l'avis de sa soeur
et de faire libérer en 14 191 son cousin
louis d'orléans enfermé à bourges et de
lui pardonner ses trahissant du passé
peut-être at-il besoin de louis pour
mener à bien une entreprise de conquête
hors du royaume qui occupe l'esprit du
souverain depuis quelques temps
[Musique]
en 14 291 l'italie est une péninsule
divisée en un grand nombre d'états duché
république au royaume qui se jalousent
et se querellent sans cesse
chacun veut affirmer sa puissance au gré
notamment de mariages arrangés ou
d'alliance vite renier le très puissant
duché de milan est dirigée par ludovic
sforza dit le mort tuteur de son neveu
le duc légitime
jean gallet as2 sforza ludovic n'hésite
pas à se rapprocher de charlot 8
car ils redoutent de dépendre un jour de
l'autre puissance de la botte
le royaume de naples ce royaume qui
représente une bonne moitié de la
superficie de l'italie occupe
obstinément l'esprit du roi de france et
va être la cause principale du
déclenchement des guerres d'italie dans
l'héritage de son père louis aux
charlots 8 trouvent les biens de du bon
roi rené d'anjou et rené d'anjou avait
eu par une une tante jeanne jeanne de
naples avait le royaume de naples en
héritage alors charles de 8 10 bompas
sait très bien ce royaume de naples
m'appartient et je vais aller le
chercher et ils se lancent dans cette
première campagne militaire vers
l'italie parce que l'italie où il va le
découvrir est un pays richissime
merveilleux couvert de deux monuments
fantastique plein d'artistes
brillantissime et en partant en italie
pour récupérer son royaume de naples
charlot 8 va quand même ouvrir la porte
à cinquante années de guerre franco
italienne
[Musique]
ferdinand premier également appelé
ferrante et d'aragon et le fils
illégitime dalphond cinq croit d'aragon
et de sicile qui a chassé du trône en 14
à 142 le roi rené d'anjou autrement
nommé le bon roi rené
ferrante et est un tyran mal aimé de son
peuple et charles wuyts va profiter de
cet état de fait ils le considèrent
comme un usurpateur et prétend récupérer
naples conformément au testament signé
par rené d'anjou qui donne alloué 11 son
père toutes les possessions de la maison
blanche
cette revendication ne peut être
satisfaite par voie diplomatique
car le royaume de naples à de puissants
alliés qui voient d'un mauvais oeil
l'arrivée des français en terre
italienne
c'est le cas des états pontificaux du
nouveau pape alexandre 6 imborgia à la
réputation sulfureuse et de la
richissime république de venise
l'intervention militaire paraît donc
inévitable mais c'est une entreprise
difficile qui demande une préparation
minutieuse et très coûteuse pour se
donner bonne conscience et justifié la
levée d'une grande armée charles witt
prétend même temps répondre à l'appel à
l'aide du pape innocent 8 prédécesseur
de borgia afin de stopper l'avancée de
l'armée ottomane qui occupe
effectivement l'autre bord de la mer
adriatique une sorte de nouvelle
croisade croisade contre le péril turc
qui depuis le milieu du siècle a détruit
l'empiré byzantin a déferlé sur les
balkans et menacent à présent l'italie
elle même beaucoup de prophétie cours à
cette époque selon lesquelles un prince
français va venir en italie et rétablir
la paix et ensuite mené la croisade la
grande croisade de la chrétienté contre
l'infidèle
mais c'est encore insuffisant cette
expédition transalpine pour réussir doit
s'assurer de la neutralité des grands
d'europe
ce que charles va payer au prix fort au
grand désarroi de sa soeur anne de
beaujeu qui voit partir en fumée
certaines provinces a kiss de main de
maître par louis 11 leur père
trois traités vont être signé le traité
d'étaples le 3 novembre 14 192 ha sur la
neutralité de l'angleterre
henri 7 reconnaît le contrôle de la
bretagne par la france à condition que
le trésor royal s'acquitte de la dette
bretonne soit 620 milles couronne d'or
et d'une indemnité supplémentaire de 120
milles couronne d'or à raison de 50
mille couronnes par an le traité de
barcelone le 19 janvier 14 993 redonne à
ferdinand ii d'aragon le roussillon et
la cerdagne
en échange de la non-intervention de
l'espagne
[Musique]
le traité de senlis le 23 mai 14 193
règles l'héritage des anciens états
bourguignon entre la france et les
habsbourgs maximilien d'autriche
récupère la dot de sa fille marguerite
la petite reine répudier à savoir
l'artois la franche comté le charolais
et noyon
[Musique]
charlot huit lances l'expédition en mars
14 294 officiellement pour une nouvelle
croisade contre les ottomans le mot
croisade permet d'atténuer une
éventuelle grogne du peuple contre le
coût exorbitant de l'effort de guerre
l'armée royale
forte d'environ 28 mille hommes franchi
le montgenèvre de septembre 14 294
quinze mille français dont 9500
cavaliers 6500 piétons suisse ou autres
1200 arbalétriers à cheval écossais
hauguel droit 500 arquebusiers à cheval
6000 italien que ludovic le more va
retirer à l'entrée imprévue des troupes
en toscane et à florence 70 pièces
d'artillerie moderne capable de tirer
son coup à l'heure sont acheminés par
voie maritime
le haut commandement est confiée à
gilles de montpensier un cousin du roi
et à louis d'orléans le rebelles
repentis
le gouvernement de la france
en l'absence de charles 8 incombe à sa
soeur anne et à son mari pierre de vos
jeux en lesquels le roi vous une totale
confiance sachant leurs compétences en
matière de politique intérieure
l'italie est de plus en plus importante
et au point d'ailleurs d'exciter
l'appétit de conquête des princes
successives de la france après pendant
plusieurs années et donc il y à la fois
en italie des oeuvres d'art
extraordinaire mais il ya aussi des
façons de renier de penser la politique
le pouvoir avec des auteurs comme
castiglione
machiavel et tout cela est extrêmement
séduisant pour des français qui sont un
petit peu encore dans la féodalité dans
le moyen-age et tout son cortège de de
sorcellerie l'entrée en italie n'est
qu'une simple formalité
charles wuyts rejoint asti le 9
septembre où il rencontre son allié du
moment ludovic le more l'homme fort du
duché de milan en même temps louis
d'orléans longe la côte méditerranéenne
émettant des routes à rapallo
une arme et aragonaises forte de cinq
mille hommes fraîchement débarqué de
gênes charles entend rejoindre son
cousin eugène mais victime de la petite
vérole il doit attendre le 6 octobre et
10 avec un certain humour pour habiller
mon visage il ne suffisait pas que juste
la petite vérole mais j'ai eu la
rougeole de la ken dieu merci j'ai
guéret l'armée royale continue alors
sans résistance à marche sur naples
charles décide cependant de passer par
florence façon de montrer sa mauvaise
humeur à pierre de médicis devant
l'étonnante neutralité observée par
celui ci
[Musique]
cela permet aux cyniques prédicateur
dominicain jérôme savonarole de mettre
en place une république aristocratique
religieuse à florence c'est à ce moment
là que ludovic le more retire les
troupes milanaise de l'expédition
derrière fin décembre quatorze 194 les
français entrent dans rome alexandre 6
alias rodrigue borgia le sulfureux
nouveau pape renonce à fuir et simule
une soumission qui ne laisse rien
augurer de bon pour la suite
la campagne militaire du roi de france
une rencontre avec charles lui tu as
quand même lieu dans les jardins du
vatican saint père je suis venu pour
faire obédiences et révérence à votre
sainteté de la façon qu'ont fait mes
prédécesseurs roi de france en janvier
14 995 sans livrer de véritables combats
à coups de petites escarmouches les
troupes françaises approche de naples
alphonse 2 conscient de son infériorité
abdique en faveur de son fils ferdinand
d' pensant ainsi mettre un frein aux
ambitions de charles lutte mais ce
dernier ne tient nullement compte de
cette passation de pouvoir manoeuvrière
et entre triomphalement dans naples en
février 14 995 faisant fuir à son tour
le tout nouveau jeune roi
l'occupation de naples est plutôt bien
accueillie par la population tant que
charles wuyts et preuve de finesse
politique en diminuant les impôts
cela conforte provisoirement sa
popularité l'italie plus prosaïquement
fait à l'époque le champ clos des
rivalités entre les grandes puissances
européennes
il y a en particulier l'aragon donc la
couronne d'aragon il y a l' empire
germanique dont l'italie du nord fait
toujours formellement partie et dans ces
conditions le roi de france ne peut pas
abandonner la scène italienne sans
perdre de son prestige sur la scène
européenne
malheureusement cette lune de miel entre
les napolitains et les français ne dure
pas il confie alors tous les postes clés
de l'administration du royaume un et
français excluant maladroitement les
seigneurs du royaume susceptible de le
soutenir
mécontent d'être exclus des affaires
politiques
ceux ci vont alors chercher des
alliances auprès des grands noble
d'italie qui commence à voir d'un très
mauvais oeil la puissance française
s'affirmer sur une moitié de la
superficie de l'italie
c'est ainsi que l'on assiste à un
brusque retournement de situation
la ligue de venise se constituer en 1495
pour faire face au danger que représente
aux yeux de ses membres les ambitions de
charlot 8 qui vient de conquérir le
royaume de naples
elle est animée par la république de
venise et comprend également le duché de
milan ainsi que deux acteurs extérieurs
à la péninsule italienne qui sont
l'empereur et le roi d'aragon
de plus les exactions d'une occupation
militaire mécontente la population c'est
d'ailleurs à cette période que
commencent les pertes en effectifs de
l'armée française fortement touchée par
un mal jusqu'à l'heure inconnues une
campagne militaire à l'étranger ça ne va
pas sans risque hélas hélas le risque
est bien ma foi c'est 2
de voir les soldats roulé boulé dans les
bras des p'tites vites alien mais les
petites italiennes ne sont pas toutes en
bonne santé si bien qu' il ya une énorme
épidémie de ce qu'on appelle le mal de
naples les français appelait ça le mal
de naples alors que les napolitains
appelé ça le mal français et il s'agit
tout simplement de la syphilis la
syphilis qui a on le sait qui aurait été
ramené par les hommes de christophe
colomb
depuis l'amérique quand le bon
christophe avait réussi à traverser
l'atlantique
constatant la fragilité de son autorité
sur le royaume de naples afin surtout de
ne pas perdre la face
charles lui décide de rentrer en france
il confie le gouvernement de naples
agile de montpensier qui est nommé vice
roi mais ne lui laisse que 3000 hommes
pour mener à bien sa mission
d'occupation de l'italie du sud
le retour en france ou plutôt la
retraite par le nord de l'italie à cause
de cette fameuse coalition ne s'annonce
pas sous les meilleurs auspices en tout
cas la progression est très lente
fortement ralentie par le transport de
l'artillerie que charles ne veut pas
abandonner
l'armée est fatigué décimé par la
syphilis il ne reste plus que huit mille
hommes environs le 6 juillet 14 100 95
26 mille hommes de la ligue de venise
empêche la traversée de la rivière tarn
charles 8 conscient de son infériorité
numérique tente en vain de négocier
il est donc obligé de livrer bataille à
fordow près de parme
l'armée française ne doit son salut qu'à
la bêtise et la cupidité de l'ennemi qui
préfèrent piller l'arrière-garde du roi
de france tantris des trésors de guerre
prix sur le sol italien
plutôt que de finaliser le combat la
furia francese emmené par charles ou 8
ans personnes et l'artillerie profite de
l'aubaine pour renverser une situation
quasi désespérée
le roi durant les violents combats force
l'admiration de ses hommes par son
courage sa ténacité dans l'action
derrière on compte 4000 morts du côté
coalisés contre 1000 du côté français
fort nous est une victoire miraculeuse
qui permet à charles de pouvoir négocier
d'autant qu'ils ne peuvent venir en aide
à louis d'orléans a siégé à novara dans
le piémont italien
[Musique]
le traité de versailles simulacre
d'accord entre charlie 8 et ludovic le
more permet l'évacuation de novare et et
la poursuite de la retraite française
sans perdre la face ni en italie ni en
france au contraire même la bataille de
fort nous est perçue en france comme une
épopée glorieuse où le roi de france
investi d'une mission divine protectrice
s'est comporté en héros
cette victoire et le départ du roi ouvre
la voie à la reconquête totale du
royaume de naples sur les français qui
est parachevée en 1497 de retour en
france en 496 désespérée de la perte du
dauphin charles orlan victime de la
rougeole
charles ou 8 ne se soucie pas du triste
sort de gilles de montpensier qui doit
évacuer naples sous la pression de
ferdinand ii d'aragon
le royaume de naples est perdu la trêve
d'alcala de henares c'est la
réconciliation entre les espagnols et
les français
l'espagne à cette époque c'est d'un côté
le royaume de casting sur lequel règne
isabelle la catholique royaume
traditionnellement allié de la france et
qui n'a pas d'intérêt particulier en
italie
et puis d'autre part le royaume d'aragon
ou plus exactement la couronne d'aragon
qui est une constellation de petits
royaumes qui est gouverné par l'époux
une isabelle la catholique ferdinand et
qui elle en revanche est engagée sur le
front italien à naples contre les
français cette sorte de traité stipule
néanmoins que ferdinand ii d'aragon roi
de castille aidera dans le futur la
france à reconquérir naples en échange
de la calabre une trêve mais une trêve
permanente à laquelle vont être joint
d'une part l'empereur et d'autre part le
roi d'angleterre henry 7 qui vient très
tardivement et sans conviction de
rejoindre la ligue de venise si bien que
cette trêve vont entraîner la
dislocation de la ligue de venise le
pape va se rapprocher de chars le 8 et
venise va rester seul isolé dans son
opposition au roi de france
ainsi à peine rentré en touraine des 14
198 charlot 8 envisage-t-il une nouvelle
expédition en italie louis d'orléans
humilie à novare et nourrit lui aussi
des rêves italien est le roi de france
n'a toujours pas de succession
[Musique]
pendant la campagne d'italie
charles 8 tombe en admiration devant l'
architecture affiner le souci de
l'esthétique et du confort des grandes
maisons et surtout les jardins
superbement dessiné cette italie en
effet est un pays riche et chacun et et
séduit est sous le charme de ce que l'on
découvre nous en france nous avons
encore les grosses citadelle les
forteresses médiévales et on arrive là
bas on découvre des oeuvres d'art à tous
les coins de rue en quelque sorte si
bien que les rois vont vouloir copier
s'inspirer et vont d'ailleurs amener
directement avec eux les artistes
italiens
c'est ainsi par exemple que le cardinal
d'amboise qui était le premier ministre
de louis xii va construire en bord de
seine entre rouen et paris
en bord de seine louis ce qui est le
premier château de la loire que le
merveilleux château de gaillon et
ensuite tous les châteaux viendront
amboise sera revu et corrigé à
l'italienne et c'est le début d'une
merveilleuse renaissance des architectes
des peintres des tapissiers des tisseurs
des jardiniers mais aussi des
philosophes des astrologues des poètes
transforme radicalement l'habitat
moyenâgeux et la façon de vivre de la
noblesse
sur le chantier d'amboise à partir de
14h 195 se côtoient désormais italien
flamand et français le style gothique
petit à petit se raffine grâce à
l'apport italien qui privilégie la
culture artistique et le confort de 14
985 à 15,140 6 ce premier mouvement
architectural et cette évolution des
moeurs votre avis de gagner l'ensemble
du territoire français les grands du
royaume s'efforçant d'imiter leur
souverain
[Musique]
amboise sonne donc le départ de la
renaissance française
la chapelle saint-hubert l'ale charlie 8
du logis royal
les deux tours cavalière tour des
minimes et tourer tôt
[Musique]
le parc sur la terrasse en sont les
premiers témoignages parmi les grands
maîtres italiens présents il faut citer
les plus célèbres fra giovanni jack ando
architecte archéologue et antiquaires
dominique au da cortona architectes sol
aubry noda forli sculpteur en terre
cuite émaillée willow watson sculpteur
paciello dames et cogliano jardini
horticulteurs luca vijay nos inventeurs
qui va construire un four capable de
faire éclore 1200 heures trois
architectes français supervise toutes
les réalisations
il s'agit de colin billard guillaume
sono et louis armand chars les
successeurs de charlot 8 vont développer
ce nouvel art de vivre qui va offrir
notamment sur les bords de la loire des
chefs-d'oeuvre d'une remarquable beauté
[Musique]
il est impossible de relater la vie de
charles 8 sont réservées quelques lignes
à anne de bretagne duchesse est reine de
france
très convoité par de nombreux
prétendants de toute l'europe depuis son
plus jeune âge
la fille de françois ii de bretagne de
marguerite deux fois après bien des
péripéties diplomatiques devient
finalement reine de france en épousant
charlet 8
son destin est d'ailleurs scellé
définitivement puisqu'elle ne peut
épouser que le successeur de son mari en
cas de décès ou d'absence de dauphin le
rôle principal dan et de donner des
enfants mal à la france elle est sacrée
reine à saint denis le 8 février 14 192
grand est rarissime honneur pour une
reine de france
[Musique]
elle a été l'épousé de 2,3 puisqu'elle a
été la femme de charlie 8
et puis ensuite la femme de louis xii
ce qui prouve elle a été aussi mère de
six enfants ce qui prouve que non pas
que c'était une grande consommatrice
d'hommes mais ça prouve aussi
l'importance politique qu'elle avait en
tant qu'héritière du de xin du duché de
bretagne
et la couche le 10 octobre 14 192 d'un
garçon charles orlan qui meurent de la
rougeole en décembre 14 295
elle perd un autre enfant mâle né avant
terme en août 14 293
une fille mort né au printemps 14 995
un garçon à un mois en quatorze 996 et
une dernière fille
peu après sa naissance en mars 14 298
ces drames afflige fortement année son
mari ce dernier au retour de l'italie et
après la mort de charles orlan décide de
réformer sa vie privée et se réfugie
dans la prière et la chasteté
il subit sans nul doute les influences
de son ermite et confident françois de
paule et du très pieux dominicain
florentin savonarole
pourtant le roi a aimé son plaisir et a
connu bon nombre d'aventurés amoureuses
il fait pourtant expulser toutes les
filles de joie de la cour
au grand dam des courtisans il faut
rappeler qu'il n'a cependant pas imposer
contrairement à son illustre grand-père
charles vii de favorite est la cour anne
au caractère bien trempé exclusive et
capricieuse n'aurait su tolérer ces deux
pratiques humiliantes pour les pauses
elle aime le roi sincèrement sans doute
à cause de sa légendaire amabilité et de
sa générosité de coeur
pourtant le physique de charles ix 8
n'est pas des plus avenants on ne
connaît pas non plus de favoris yann et
la mort de son mari la plonge dans une
réelle est très profonde tristesse
elle prend elle-même l'initiative de
l'originalité et du gigantisme du
tombeau de charlot 8 à saint denis
elle assume ainsi jusqu'au bout son rôle
de femme politique au service de son roi
veuve à 21 ans elle sait aussi qu'elle
va épouser louis d'orléans le futur
louis xii avec lequel elle n'a pas
vraiment d'affinités seule la raison
d'état compte et c'est le trait
principal du caractère obstiné de la
duchesse de bretagne
elle doit donner un dauphin à la france
[Rires]
[Musique]
depuis quelque temps après le retour
d'italie
la perte de ses enfants et son étonnante
volonté de chasteté leroy maigri tel
sous terre lyon 11 avant son trépas le 7
avril
1498 charlot 8es dans son beau et
nouveau château d'amboise et après
déjeuner il rend visite à la reine anne
de bretagne dans ses appartements
la reine vient de perdre un enfant
prématuré et le roi pour lui changer les
idées lui propose de l'emmener voir une
partie de jeu de paume dans les fossés
du château en la précédent dans un
escalier
il va heurter du front une porte il
assiste à la partie et à la fin de
celle-ci de visons avec son confesseur
tombe brusquement à la renverse dans les
bras de deux de ses fidèles compagnons
d'armes
présent à ses côtés à forno après neuf
heures de coma entrecoupé de bref retour
de la parole leroy rend l'âme plongeon
la reine dans un état de grande et
sincère détresse beaucoup de
supputations auxquels s'ajoutent des
soins inappropriés de médecins
incompétents rahmati ce taux maximum
l'événement on parle même
d'empoissonnement philippe de valperga
gentilhomme savoyard qui assistent aux
derniers moments du roi dira plus tard
au sujet des médecins il lui arrachèrent
les poils de la barbe et de la tête et
lui firent beaucoup d'autres martyrs
afin que la qatar ou de l'étoffé
en réalité avec le recul il semble que
charles 8 comme son père souffre depuis
longtemps de troubles circulatoires le
coup de tête accidentel n'est que le
déclencheur fatale d'une hémorragie
cérébrale
le dernier valois direct meurt à 27 ans
ces funérailles sont somptueuses 7000
personnes dont 400 pauvre porteurs de
torche accompagné le cortège funèbre à
la basilique des rois à saint denis
juste reconnaissance pour un roi aimé de
ses sujets qu'il s'est évertué à ne pas
accabler d'impôts tous les jours sans
ccg fait effet donné ordre au fait de la
justice de ce royaume
son coeur est déposé en la basilique
notre-dame de cléry à cléry saint-andré
auprès de son père le roi louis xii
dans l'ensemble on peut dire que sous le
règne de charles ix 8 le royaume
continue sa convalescence et le fait
même que le roi et puis s'absenter
longuement du royaume sans soubresauts
majeurs montre bien la maturité
politique attente par l'état royal et la
stabilité que les beaux jeux et charles
vite ont su conserver
mais son oeuvre reste inachevée la
france est ruinée par le coût démesuré
de la campagne d'italie et se trouve
amputée de territoire âprement gagné par
louis 11
néanmoins la bretagne fait désormais
partie du royaume et la renaissance dont
charles 8 est sans conteste l'initiateur
va donner un souffle nouveau à la
politique en général y asseoir le
formidable rayonnement artistique de la
france dans toute l'europe
le roi charles ii 8 est mort vive le roi
louis doses
[Musique]